all right
Trinity Trinity we'll just get right
into it you have an interesting is it a
kink or a fetish what do you call it
yeah I would say it's a kink I don't
know what the difference I don't know
what same thing maybe yeah tell me about
what you're into um so I do rope bondage
um I'm a bottom or a bunny or model
whatever rope receiver I'm the one who
gets tied up and this is something that
you you like being tied yeah I love it
it's one of my it's one of my
favorite like top three favorite things
I like to do as a human really yeah how
did you discover that this was your
thing um so I was in college and somehow
my College library had like a photo book
that had rope bondage photos in it and I
was like what the hell is this like I
thought it was like the hottest thing
that I had ever seen um and I just liked
how
I liked the Artistry of it it's like
very beautiful kink like it's like the
body becomes this kind of like art
object it gets like decorated and I like
it's like a canvas it's like a canvas
yeah like it's and um and you you get to
I don't know seeing these models getting
like tied up and there's a res the
Restraint of it felt really appealing to
me um yeah it just I don't know it's
just hot I think it's
hot and through the internet you're able
to find practitioners of this right yeah
so I it took me kind of a while to get
around to like between the time I
figured out that I liked it and then um
finding someone was like a it was like a
15-year Gap and um I think that's
because like to me it's so obvious that
it's hot I figured it would like I would
just stumble upon somebody who like
wanted to do it with me but apparently
it's not that common so I eventually I
was like okay I need to like find
somebody to do this with um yeah these
Partners is this a sexual thing first
off right yeah so it is sexual in the
sense that there's like eroticism and
gratification and sometimes it includes
like overtly sexual acts like having
erogenous Zone stimulated or orgasm play
um but for a suspension there isn't that
there's no like I mean you can do
intercourse in a suspension but it's
kind of a lot of like mechanics so a lot
of times for a suspension there's it's
not like sometimes you're just being
tied up and that's it yeah interesting
yeah and you have partners that are into
romantic partners that are into this or
yeah so that's actually how I met my
romantic partner that he found me on
FetLife and we started tying and then
our relationship Grew From there so that
was the
origin so you guys have it all worked
out yeah it's great I feel really lucky
you have a closet full of ropes and
things like that yeah he handles it yeah
he has the closet he he he does all the
yeah he does all the stuff and I get to
is this
masochism there's a masochistic element
to it for sure so when I'm being tied
when I'm being
suspended it's like all of my body
weight is being held up and distributed
over like a very small amount of space
right so that
hurts um
and yeah masochism the thing the
masochist side of it is
um the enjoyment that I get I think out
of the masochism is that I have
to challenge myself mentally to like
surrender to it and release into it and
I also can't think about anything else
like if I'm in physical pain I'm not
thinking about what I have to buy at the
grocery store I'm not thinking about the
other stressful things in my life I'm
just focused
on like surrendering to that it put your
brain into another mode of totally yeah
I remember the very very first time I
got tied up it wasn't a suspension it
was like just for a photo shoot and the
photographer was like just so you know
I'm not trying to set a mood I'm not
trying to like create an experience for
you he I think he even said the phrase
like food photography like we're staging
this I'm not trying to you know get you
into a state and I was like sure
whatever what whatever works for you I
was just curious to try and the second
he got me into he did me uh he did a
chest harness so my arms were behind my
back and there's rope around my chest
and there was a little bit of rope not
tight at all but um very safe but around
my neck here and I
just I just dropped into this meditative
State even though he wasn't trying to
like make me feel something it was just
the physical sensation of the rope and
having to be conscious of my breath
because it was like in order for the
Rope to be tight enough to stay in place
it has to kind of restrict the um the
rib cage a little bit so then I'm forced
to redirect my breath downwards which is
sort of like a forced meditation like
forced belly breath so yeah it feels
like a meditation it feels like what I
imagine and is achieving orgasm easier
this way
um no I don't think it makes it's not
really about the orgasm for me it's more
about the whole yeah it's a holistic
body experience and like a journey it's
like more dimensional than that I mean
it's definitely I'll tell you it's
definitely fun to have an orgasm while
I'm in rope that's like that's a blast
but it's it's not like it makes it
easier to get there and just trying to
understand yeah the the motivation
behind doing it yeah do you think there
was something from your your past your
childhood that uh made this appealing no
so I think that
[Music]
um I think that it's just like it's a
sensation thing like I think just the
sensation of cuz you know how like when
we hug each other we're imitating like
being held as a baby and the reason
babies like being held is because it
reminds them of being held like in the
womb so there's like a there's like a
holding quality so I would say if
there's anything in my like whatever
childhood it would be being held but
everybody everybody had that so that's
not like unique to me um you know and if
you think about different interests like
like if if we were talking about crochet
or if we're talking about like I don't
know skydiving or something you wouldn't
necessarily say oh is there something in
their your childhood that led you to
this you might be like oh how did you
discover you liked this right but I
think because it's sexual I think then
sometimes it's like well did something
did something go wrong did something
happen to you and um there's not like an
incident or like abuse or anything that
happened that now I can only get off
with rope I think I just discovered
something that gives me great
pleasure and yeah and actually um it
expands my sense of what erogenous zones
are so like the classic ones are what's
covered by a bikini right but also when
I have rope around my waist that feels
erotic to me or when I have rope around
my like inner thighs that feels like a
similar kind of arousal that I would get
from having an orog ayous Zone touched
um I also to me the Rope is like a
conduit for intimacy like I love how
my partner does something to me to
affect me um through the rope and that
like to me that cranks up the sense of
intimacy so as it it's not so much
focused on orgasm it's sort of more like
the experience of feeling really
connected to someone and also there's
like a ritual kind of quality to it
because it's like you know we start we
press play on the music get the Rope
stuff set up and then go into this kind
of like separate world where it's just
me and my partner and the Rope kind of
connecting us and we go through this
journey where I'm being challenged and
they're like using my body kind of as
clay or as a you know canvas for what
they want and then we end it and the
Rope comes off and it's like so it's
like going into a special world together
that's heightened intimacy it's treated
like an art form yeah absolutely it is
yeah I think the Artistry is a big part
of what appeals to me about it too
because there's so much space for
creativity within is this always done
just privately just the two of you or is
it sometimes done publicly um sometimes
we go to events we've done it at events
before um I I don't like to some people
will do full-on rope performances where
they stage it and they have costumes and
stuff I'm not really into that um
because to me if I'm staging a
performance there's a lot of like thinky
think that I kind of have to do and the
whole point for me is to not have to be
thinking yeah it turns off your brain
yes yeah like it turns on like you know
the crawl at the bottom of the screen
where it's like this is also happening
like that goes away it's just like it
turns down all the volume on everything
else it's like a it's a flow I think
Flow State have you ever had Partners do
this where it you maybe the
communication wasn't so good or became a
problem
um well no so I think one of the things
that I love about it I can imagine
things going bad yeah yeah so I have had
I have had injuries um because you know
it's um the Rope restraint can cause uh
numbness and if there's numbness then
you can't then it's harder to tell if um
a nerve is being compressed so I have
had like prolonged numbness um and in
different parts of my body eventually it
went away um but in all those cases the
communication was on my end for like
some some kind of alarm Bell was going
off where I was like I don't know about
this I don't know about this but I was
in this kind of like loopy State and I
also in many cases I wanted to finish it
I had some kind of ego about finishing
it so then afterward I was like oh [__]
now I like when like my boob was numb
for or the side of my you don't want to
be seen as a wimp maybe that was before
like early on I think I wanted to be
seen like yeah like I could follow
through but now I know that that's
that's just ego like if you need to come
out you need to come out you
know
um yeah I think
that when going into something that's
this risky the communication has to
be spotless it has to be I mean and it's
not going to be spotless we're both
flawed humans but we we have to do our
best to
create like the best communication we
possibly can to like eliminate yeah
that's that's what I've learned with all
these Kink and fetish interviews I've
done is the communication is is always
number one
yes and that's one of the things that I
love about it I'm like I love the
activity but I also love talking to my
partner beforehand this is the mood I'm
in what kind of thing do you want to do
I also love talking to them about it
afterward how did that go for you what
was that experience like for you so it's
holistic intimacy the intimacy is not
just in the moment when we're doing the
activity it's also around how we talk
about it so like um I do some like
misogyny play like some kind of like
objectification stuff of like being tied
up maybe in a way that's very like
exposing or like sometimes when my
partner takes me downhill like step on
me like step on my face or something and
um the reason that I like doing that
with him is because I know that he
doesn't actually think I'm just a piece
of meat he doesn't actually think that
I'm lower than him but in that moment we
get to kind of play with that taboo of
me being like his little doormat you
know so it's it's playing with the
playing in the shadow we playing in the
dark space that makes it fun but the
masochism is something that appeals to
you for sure yeah I think that I think
um the pain the feeling of pain so it's
sort of like there's like a threshold
with the pain so it starts where it's
like ow ow ow ow ow I don't like this I
don't like this and then it goes into
like
oh there's like a quiet that comes
afterward and then whenever what's
causing the pain is taken away then
there's this huge relief like a huge
catharsis like crying or laughing or
just being a little noodle you've done
this with multiple partners yes yeah so
my partner ties with other people I tie
with other people I've tied with other
people in the past and it's something
that I explore with different different
people and it's not necessarily a
romantic partner like it could be
someone who I just do that with that
activity with and the the masochism does
it get into other things other than just
r play sure yeah so I've done um impact
play like being hit with hands or
paddles um I've done um there were some
pretty black and blue oh yeah I've got
yeah like sometimes bruising the
bruising thing is sort of fun because
it's like evidence of a good time you
know um yeah the bruising yeah so it's
not always the goal to like have a
visible bruise but it's sort of fun like
I think it there's also an element of
surrender in the bruising too it's like
I'm surrendering my body to allow you to
make a mark that's going to last and
someone else will notice it so it's sort
of like entrusting my body to have this
intense thing happen to it and is your
partner a dominant typically yeah so
they they enjoy inflicting pain on you
or or tying you up or restraining you
yes totally yeah yeah so that that
Dynamic has to be in place yeah so the
way that it works for us is that that
Dynamic is in place for for the duration
of the Rope session or like for the
duration of the sexual intimacy so
during that time I occupy this
submissive role and he occupies this
dominant role or dominant energy I would
say um but then the rest of the time
we're just a regular couple and even
there are even situations where he kind
of wants me to like take over like we
were preparing for a party and he was
like you drive I don't know what to get
he was like this isn't a collaboration
you decide what nextn it's interesting
how those roles can flip yeah and I I
really I like that flip because I feel
really supported by him um and held and
nurtured by him in our sexual Dynamic so
that kind of feels like a springboard
for me to then take a more I wouldn't
even say dominant role but take a take
um initiative in other areas and feel
supported like knowing that there's
balance you know do you think there are
a lot of people that might have things
that they would really enjoy like this
that they just don't even want to
explore yeah yeah I do I I feel like um
shame
or kind of stigma or the anxiety around
it could stop people from even
considering that like they might they
might like it or the idea that like oh
does that mean something bad about me
like oh I like pain does that mean
I'm um that there's I'm damaged there's
something wrong with me oh I like being
um degraded or I like I like doing
degrading I like inflicting pain we're
all damag we're there there's something
wrong with all of us I know we all have
scars yeah it makes us interesting yeah
that's it makes life interesting I think
yeah and and does this is this an
exploration for you or or do you feel
like you've found your thing and this is
it both I think this is this is the
sight of the exploration so I feel like
even in the time that I since I've
started doing rope to now my Rel
relationship to it has evolved like when
I started I was like I want this to be
sexual there has to be Sexual Energy
otherwise it's not fun now I've kind of
expanded to be like it can be overtly
sexual we can do orgasm stuff we can do
this but it can also be more of a more
of a dance more of a shared thing so I
think the Rope is my thing rope is my
love um as far as kinks are concerned
but I think that's going to continue to
expand and evolve because like you said
it's an art form so there's so many
different ways to play and does your I
don't mean to be too I try not to get
too personal with this stuff but is is
your sex life always involving rope no
sometimes it's it's conventional and no
yeah um I do like I I I think um Power
Play is like extremely hot so I like
that to be involved but that's not even
a requirement either you know because
also sometimes you don't want to get the
Rope out like rope is such a whole
production and so sometimes you know you
just want
the sometimes you don't want that extra
element to have to kind of consider and
track is there a lot of preparation and
work into like um setting this up or is
it just like get some rope and do it um
it's not too much preparation but it is
you do have to kind of talk through what
kind of mood you're in and you do have
to and there's a high level of focus
required from my partner to be paying
attention to my safety you know so
you're hanging from
yeah I'm dangling from the ceiling yeah
yeah yeah your the photos you showed me
are sometimes
like you're at the mercy of your
yes yeah I it's funny because I I showed
to me it doesn't feel as hardcore as I
think it looks like to me when I'm in
that I'm yeah I'm in pain or I'm in an
I'm having an intense moment for sure
but uh I've showed it to a friend the
other night and she was like oh my God
like I can't believe you do this and I
was like well it's fun I don't know like
what do you think a lot of people don't
understand about this fetish Kink world
I think there's a perception of the
fetish world that it's very like dark
and mysterious and you'll go like to
some Underground club where there's like
a Yakuza boss in the corner with like
handrolled cigarettes and like a bunch
of guys and leather vests and little
police hats and actually most of the
people who do kink
also did theater in high school it's
like a lot of a lot of kinky people are
like very nerdy it's like sex nerds like
people who are like o we can do we can
do sex in a fun way like so I think that
it the way it's presented a lot of times
in the media there's this kind of chic
you know 50 Shades of Gray like sexy
billionaire kind of idea about it and in
fact like it's like pretty regular even
like nerdy people who are doing it and
um and it's a lot
[Music]
more uh it's a lot less like seedy I
think than people maybe imag the energy
I've picked up on from the people I've
interviewed who are into it seems to be
the most genuine and down toe and
healthy totally of of all the people
I've interviewed yeah I well that's such
a I'll take that as a compliment I and I
I do think there's a lot of people who
have invested in the um investigating
their own desires and who have decided
like my desire is worth um examining and
pursuing and finding people to do that
with and I'll tell you too like after I
do a rope session I'm the sweetest
friendliest I'm such a happy puppy I'm
like tipping extra I'm like saying you
know saying hi like being nice to the
person at the grocery store like it
makes me it's such a fun fulfilling
thing and it makes
me like a better neighbor it makes me a
better it seems like the people that are
into it and have found their thing yeah
and there's a whole
wide Myriad of things yeah that people
could be into but the people that have
found it they exude this genuine
happiness yeah I they've found their
thing yes they're just it's like their
little secret totally and they come on
my channel and they want to talk about
it and share it to help others but
everybody everybody judges them as oh
this person's a freak right no it's not
I mean yeah I think like one wish I
would have for Humanity is for other
people to
find that thing for them so it's like
I'm not saying everybody would like rope
as much as I do I know for a fact that's
not the case but I would love for people
to be able to like get rid of the
preconceptions get rid of the shame
whatever's stopping them from finding
the thing that lights them up in that
way like CU I want other people to have
the kind of like pleasure and enjoyment
that I get to have I feel so grateful
every time when I do a rope session with
someone I always say thank you so much
like thank you for taking all the
classes and practicing and learning
thank you for buying the Rope thank you
for setting it up thank you for making
the time for me like I feel so so
grateful so so special it's such a
special thing to get to do it seems like
it just grounds you yes 100% that's a
beautiful way to frame it yeah and it's
like the people that have found their
thing for you it's rope for somebody
else it's something else yeah they've
they found their thing and it's just
like yeah it enriches their their life
absolutely absolutely it does how would
somebody if they wanted to explore what
their thing was how would they go about
it well I think start with the first
thing is to start with um maybe you know
what's something that you maybe don't
want to admit to yourself or you feel
some type of like weird way about and
like look like kind of like shine a
light in the corners and be like is
there something that I've always sort of
been curious about or always sort of
wanted to explore and then um and then I
would say like if it and if it's
something in the in the Kink sphere you
know like um find I think classes are a
really great place to start classes or
like it's a Munch is like a gathering
where people get together and they just
talk there's no like kinky activities
happening you can kind of demystify the
like social F life is one of the
websites there yeah FTI you can go on
FTI and go on the there's different
groups for different interests but yeah
a munch it just just a Munch just means
like we're going to like have snacks and
talk about Kink and you don't nobody's
there like wearing everyone's just
wearing regular clothes and just talking
so that's like a really great place to
start and like enter the social scene
and get to know people let's just talk
about the United States do do you think
our country is a little too uptight
about sex and and everything sex related
I think that there's a lot of like
tension and
politicization around like bodies in
general and bodies expressing themselves
in general and I think that that almost
sets up an atmosphere where people feel
like in order to express themselves they
have to pick a side and that is a lot of
pressure um to be like well but I just I
just want to express myself this way but
now I'm aligning myself with this
particular group and now this other
group is going to be mad at me and that
can really like Cloud the waters around
like what you what do you love finding
what you love so um I think yeah like
turning down the noise on like all the
different sides and factions is the best
way to find like one's own thing and you
know clear clear away the noise not
worry about what other people are going
to project onto your own expression
self- expression what was your childhood
like growing up um I was in a really big
family I was the second oldest of
eight um big old big old family um and
oldest girl and I think I had like a
strong sense of um like responsibility
for my younger siblings like I wanted to
look out for them I wanted to take care
of them um and you know when you're in a
big family like there's a lot of
different social dynamics right it's a
more complex kind of social ecosystem so
a lot of different individual
relationships and also
like it's not helicopter parenting you
know nobody's being like well did you
like the dinner it's like that's what
was that's dinner you know um so I think
that made me kind of like self-reliant
in a certain way and it also made me um
very aware of like wanting to you know
take care of other people take care of
other people and that's something I've
learned to rebalance as an adult to be
like oh not everyone are my like like
not everyone is like a you know a
younger child who like needs me to like
help them like people people can kind of
take care of it on their own you know um
like I can take care of myself like I
remember when I went to college everyone
else was like oh man I have to do my
laundry and I was like oh what a relief
I'm only doing my laundry you know so
like I think that I had like I think
that responsibility that sense of
responsibility has benefited me um
and yeah I yeah I think that that was
kind of the childhood set up yeah so
fairly normal pretty pretty stable like
we moved one time my dad had the same
job all the way through um yeah your
parents stayed married they stayed yeah
that's great yeah that's that's rare
nowadays yeah it
is in Trinity what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life in life o wow that's a big
one
[Music]
um I've learned that taking good care of
myself myself taking care of my heart
taking care of my needs is what enables
me to take care of other
people um and not to get in the way of
other people's life lessons because I
think I know
better you can do a better job of it
right because I think because I'm the
big sister because I know better yeah
just letting people have their their
experiences and being there to support
them through it if they want my support
but not trying to get in there and
control it excellent all right Trinity
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you very interesting thank
you